[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend hinein wir nehmen
sie am anfang dieser sendung mit in ein
gebiet aus dem berichterstattung sehr
schwierig ist und gerade deshalb umso
interessanter und wichtiger
erstmal weil es dort nicht ungefährlich
ist auch für reporterinnen und reporter
und dann vor allem weil viele menschen
dort nicht frei und offen reden wollen
aus angst etwas falsches zu sagen
kollegen des französischen öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehens ist dennoch eine
bemerkenswerte reportage gelungen sie
waren mit russischen einheiten unterwegs
an orten im südosten der ukraine in
denen die menschen jetzt unter
russischer besatzung leben sie zeigen
szenen die verstören und die manchmal
geradezu absurd anmutende lacroix
alexandra damms beck und felix lorenz
berichten
mario pohl süd ost ukraine die die stadt
in trümmer gelegt haben bringen
hilfsgüter
alles war gut und lief jetzt ist alles
zerstört
erzählt doch kein quatsch sie ist doch
nur hier um zu provozieren
bist du nicht wegen der hilfe da was
erzählst du denn
es liegt spannung in der luft und
trotzdem geht das leben in denen von
russland besetzten gebieten der ukraine
irgendwie weiter das heißt auch es wird
wieder geheiratet wie hier in berlin zu
80 kilometer von mario pohl entfernt zum
ersten mal seit beginn des krieges nur
jetzt eben in weiß blau rot statt blau
gelb und das soll alle welt sehen
ich bitte dich maximum das jawort
die russische hymne zur trauung
brautpaare die vor freude strahlen
[Musik]
das läuft gut
wir sind sehr sehr glücklich
es ist ein wichtiger tag für die stadt
und für uns und wir sind sehr stolz auf
das land auf welches land fragt der
französische journalist
auf russland
freudenschüsse zum bund fürs leben
während sich wenige kilometer entfernt
soldaten töten russland hat in den
besetzten regionen bürgermeister
installiert die sagen was putin will
momentan haben wir eine militärisch
zivil geführte administration unsere
zukunft sehen wir mit russland auch in
milito pohl wird das demonstriert der
zentrale platz getaucht in sowjetische
farben in vorbereitung zum tag des
sieges der roten armee über nazi
deutschland am 9 mai noch vor einigen
wochen haben hier die anwohner gegen die
besatzer protestiert jetzt ist zumindest
offiziell nicht mehr viel davon übrig
ich kam mit der roten flagge um den sieg
russlands zu feiern ich habe keine angst
vor gar nichts weil wir schon immer gut
mit russland gelebt haben die preise
sind hoch sie haben neue fahnen gehisst
vorher war es unsere und es sind immer
soldaten hier nicht unsere
was denken sie darüber fragt das
französische tv team das ist schwer zu
sagen wir sind neutral
lassen sie es uns masse formulieren in
den besetzten gebieten der ukraine hat
eine neue zeitrechnung begonnen zum teil
wird der rubel eingeführt russland
versucht seinen einfluss auszuweiten in
allen bereichen des lebens tag für tag
neben dem orthodoxen osterfest und
neujahr der vielleicht höchste feiertag
im russischen kalender der neunte mai
der tag des sieges der sowjetarmee über
hitler deutschland einen tag den der
russische präsident wie wir gerade an
den vorbereitungen gesehen haben nutzen
wird nicht nur um zurückzuschauen
der militärhistoriker sönke neitzel von
der uni potsdam ist wieder bei uns im
heute-journal professor neitzel guten
abend schön gute nannte sievers es würde
zum historischen anlass ja passen einen
abschluss zu markieren wäre das eine
gelegenheit für wladimir putin den krieg
zu stoppen naja ich glaube wir hoffen
dass das er das macht wir alle hoffen
dass dieser fürchterliche krieg
möglichst bald vorbei ist und am 9 mai
1945 endete ja was es entweder krieg der
zweite weltkrieg in europa und von daher
wäre es ja ein schönes geschenk an
europa wenn am 9 mai
2022 auch dieser krieg endet und putin
in einer großen rede ich weiß sie den
sieg von mir aus verkündet aber man dann
irgendwie zu friedensverhandlungen oder
zumindest einem waffenstillstand kommt
aber ich fürchte da ist eher der wunsch
der vater des gedanken ich fürchte wir
müssen uns auf einen weiteren motor
lanka jahrelangen krieg einstellen
bleibt noch mal moment bei dieser option
von der wir alle hoffen die
möglicherweise tatsächlich gezogen wird
am ende könnte denn putin aus seiner
sicht jetzt sagen ja ich habe gesiegt
angesichts der aktuellen militärischen
lage
angesichts seines der macht seines
propaganda apparat kann eigentlich alles
sagen er kann zahlen das was erreicht
wurde in einen sieg
diskursiv und formen wirken würde das in
der wissenschaft sagen also er hat
immerhin 20 prozent der ukraine erobert
er hat zwar noch nicht ganz den dort
aber man kann das natürlich geschickt
irgendwie so formen in den medien dass
man sagt das ist ein sieg und man kann
entsprechende zahlen nennen und wir
haben einige eine gesteuerte
medienlandschaft also das kann er schon
tun kann das ist ja auch eine eine idee
die die experten diskutieren er kann
einseitig an waffenstillstand verkünden
und sagen so das ist jetzt erreicht um
in ruhe kraft zu schöpfen um dann auch
zahlen zu argumentieren ja wir
verteidigen diese neu gewonnenen gebiete
ja nur gegen den angriff der nazis aus
der ukraine und des westens oder wie man
das dann immer formulieren will denkbar
professionals und davor warnt jetzt der
britische verteidigungsminister wäre
allerdings auch das gegenteil putin
nutzt diesen tag um noch massiver
zuzuschlagen also so eine art
generalmobilmachung wie hätte man sich
das vorzustellen
bei den begriff generell machen denkt
der historiker wie ich immer an den juli
1914 als millionen herre zu den fahnen
gerufen wurden als die reservisten
einberufen
das sind in russland bis zu eine
millionen an aber auch da muss man sehen
um was geht es eigentlich wenn putin
diesen schritt tut ist es aus meiner
sicht zunächst ein politisches signal
ein politisches signal und den westen so
als eine reaktion auf die
waffenlieferungen und auch auf die reden
der amerikaner und so weiter die ukraine
zu unterstützen ein politisches signal
der krieg wird weitergehen eine andere
frage er sie was ist dann was folgt
eigentlich militärisch also wie viel
soldaten wären wirklich einberufen
welche ausbildung haben sie und so
weiter aber es ist dann ein signal der
krieg geht weiter nur so oder so ist
meine einschätzung leider muss ich sagen
dass der krieg nicht am neunten mal
vorbei sein wird und selbst wenn wir
einen waffenstillstand hätten würde das
ja nicht bedeuten dass dieser krieg
wirklich gelöst ist der konflikt
wirklich gelöst ist und ich glaube so
oder so leider muss ich unterstreichen
wird der konflikt und auch das kämpfen
und auch das töten so muss man es ja
sagen weitergehen
würde putin tatsächlich so eine art
generalmobilmachung irgendeiner form
ausrufen wie würde dann die russische
gesellschaft reagieren aus ihrer sicht
haben das ist auch da es ist schwer zu
beurteilen dann wir haben ein bisschen
wunschdenken natürlich würde das
eigentlich bedeuten dass diese
spezialoperation nicht wirklich
erfolgreich war denn wenn sie
erfolgreich gewesen wäre hätte man ja
nicht general wo wir machen müssen aber
da müssen wir immer berücksichtigen dass
wir eine ein freies mediensystem haben
dass es in russland so nicht gibt also
auch das kann man natürlich irgendwie
verkaufen als die spezialoperation ist
beendet und jetzt müssen wir uns gegen
den westen verteidigen es birgt aber die
gefahr wenn er wirklich hunderttausende
russische reservisten einberufen werden
dass das auch zu protesten kommt und
dass man dann auch merkt die jungen
leute vielleicht auch aus den städten
wollen eigentlich nicht an die front und
sie wollen nicht kämpfen schon gar nicht
gegen die ukraine lassen sie uns zum
frost professoren als er bitte nochmal
ganz generell reden der neunte mai 8 x
19 x ende des zweiten weltkriegs im
westen heißt es seitdem immer niemals
wieder ist dieses datum in russland
anders geprägt ja unbedingt also in
russland heißt es ja zur zeit und das
können wir in den russischen medien
lesen wir können es auch nochmal machen
und noch mal machen müssen wir ja sehen
es gibt einen ein vormarsch wirklich der
roten armee bis nach berlin es ist ein
großer erfolg und das wird dann auch als
jahr ein bisschen als kraftmeierei
gesehen wägt euch nicht in sicherheit
wir können auch noch mal vor marschieren
wir können auch noch mal siegen also ist
es eben nicht dieses zumindest jetzt
nicht in den letzten jahren nicht nur
dieses nie wieder krieg sondern wir
können einen krieg gewinnen
professor silva das von der uni potsdam
herzlichen dank für diese analyse und
diese hintergründe auch heute abend
wieder bei uns ganz herzlichen dank
es ist das sechste sanktionspaket aus
europa richtung russland es kommt noch
mit einigen offenen termin fragen
verknüpft und es geht ums öl und damit
ans eingemachte für europa wo mehrere
länder noch mehr oder weniger starkem
russischen öl hängen und so hofft die eu
auch für wladimir putin die präsidentin
der eu kommission ursula von der leyen
heute vor dem europäischen parlament
die botschaft an putin war von anfang an
sehr klar wenn du eine invasion und
einen krieg in der ukraine auslöst wirst
du ein ganz ganz hohen preis zahlen und
schritt für schritt mit den sanktionen
setzen wir das auch durch uns ist daran
gelegen dass es ihm nicht möglich ist
auf dauer diese kriegsmaschinerie
aufrecht zu erhalten
bis jahresende soll es in der eu einen
schrittweisen importstopp für rohöl und
ölprodukte aus russland geben auch für
deutschland sind da noch einige fragen
zu klären
und das nicht nur bei diesem thema
selten hatte eine bundesregierung einen
start mit derartigen herausforderungen
insofern ist eine klausurtagung eine
gute idee um alle baustellen mal durch
sprechen zu können noch dazu in
malerischer atmosphäre auf der anderen
seite hatten fast 36 stunden
kabinettsklausur auf schloss meseberg
dann nur praktisch noch ein thema den
krieg und seine folgen industrie
typisch meseberg dörfliche idylle vor
den toren berlins die polizisten
eigentlich abgestellt für die sicherheit
des kabinetts versuchen sich als
tierfotografen für die ampel ein moment
der ruhe nach einem regierungsbeginn mit
pandemie und krieg der zauber des
aufbruchs er ist verflogen aufbruchs
mäßig war die stimmung jetzt nicht
sondern das war eine phase von also die
in den letzten monaten sondern es war
eine phase von höchster konzentration
und auch einen tiefen bewusst sein dass
wir gerade einen historischen moment
erleben und für den bestehen müssen als
regierung als deutschland und in europa
gelöste atmosphäre
doch der ukraine krieg überschattet
alles dessen folgen diskutieren sie für
die deutsche außen- und innenpolitik für
die deutsche wirtschaft für die emmy der
welt putin so hält der kanzlerfest habe
sich verkalkuliert
denn was er bekommt ist eine stärkere
nato ist die stärkere organisation von
sicherheit auch an den östlichen staaten
des nato gebietes was er bekommen hat
ist eine einige europäische union eine
eu die heute ein öl-embargo gegen
russland vorliegt lange hatte sich
deutschland dagegen gestemmt nun sei man
bereit wohlwissend es wird regionen wie
schwedt und leuna hart treffen auch zu
höheren energiepreisen kommen die
übergangsfrist ist so ausreichend lang
dass wir alle vorkehrungen treffen
können um alternativen für russisches öl
in deutschland zu schaffen
vorkehrungen treffen heißt nicht dass
sie sich gleich realisieren zwei
konkrete gesetze mit blick auf russland
bringt das kabinett auf den weg zum
einen will man den aufbau von
flüssiggasterminals
vorantreiben und russische oligarchen
sollen gezwungen werden ihr vermögen in
deutschland offen zu legen das wäre ein
ganz neues instrument um die
durchsetzung bestehender sanktionen
gegen natürliche personen gegen
juristische personen um das
schlagkräftiger zu machen und auch das
gab s noch trotzig macht scholz erneut
klar er wolle derzeit nicht nach kiew
reisen da die ukraine den
bundespräsidenten ausgeladen hätte
glaube ich kann für uns alle drei sagen
dass es für die deutsche regierung auch
für das deutsche volk ein problem ist
dass der bundespräsident
gebeten wurde nicht zu kommen das ist
eine angelegenheit partei ich jetzt sage
dass es wo die ukraine auch ihren
beitrag zu leisten muss selbstbewusst
gibt sich stolz nachdem der streit um
waffenlieferungen die ampel
durchgerüttelt hat berichte über
konflikte in der koalition
unzutreffend ein ich verfolge man eine
zitat präzise linie sie sehen also eine
in der frage was ist zu tun vollständig
geschlossene regierung ich weiß dass sie
das enttäuschend finden aber es ist der
fall
demonstrative einigkeit und harmonie
nach 36 stunden kabinettsklausur nach
fünf monaten ampel regierung die idylle
von meseberg sollte dabei wohl helfen
mehr zum geplanten öl boykott nachher im
heute-journal update darin auch fragen
von nason guckte mir an den wirtschafts
und energieminister von brandenburg
einem bundesland das besonders betroffen
wäre
die folgen des russischen angriff auf
die ukraine erhalten auch das schöne
mecklenburg vorpommern in atem nicht so
sehr das land selbst er die
landesregierung die dafür aber enorm die
regierung in schwerin hat er eine
stiftung gegründet unter dem ebenso
wohlklingenden wie irreführenden namen
klima und umweltschutz mv jetzt kommen
immer mehr details ans licht die einen
anderen zweck der stiftung beleuchten
mit verdeckten geschäften den bau der
nord-stream-pipeline
gegen sanktionen der usa abzusichern das
ganze ist derart undurchsichtig dass es
selbst um die frage ob die stiftung
jetzt aufgelöst werden kann einen
bizarren streit gibt zwischen
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig und
ihrem amtsvorgänger ein streit der am
ende für beide gefährlich werden kann
wie bernd mosebach berichtet
halb zwölf heute mittag wird weitemeier
auf dem weg ins schweriner schloss in
ihrem gepäck hat die professorin für
stiftungsrecht ein gutachten an ihrer
seite den innenminister das papier in
auftrag gegeben von der landesregierung
soll zunächst den fraktionen präsentiert
werden das urteil der experten ist
messerscharf
die umstrittene klimastiftung kann nicht
nur sie muss aufgelöst werden
anschließend pressekonferenz und ihre
begründung ein ziel der stiftung nord
stream 2 fertig zu bauen ist erreicht
das andere ziel umweltprojekte zu
fördern kann gar nicht mehr erreicht
werden weil die öffentliche akzeptanz
dafür mittlerweile fehlt die stiftung
hat keinen zweck mehr erstmal
unterstützungs vorstand der für mich
fest aus sich das gutachten ansehen dann
ist er nach einschätzung der gutachterin
gefordert die auflösung vorzunehmen und
wenn das dann tatsächlich unter bleiben
sollte dann wäre erst quasi nachrangig
und nur als notnagel die
stiftungsaufsicht ihrerseits in der
prüfungspflicht wie sie damit umgeht
heißt im klartext wenn sich die stiftung
nicht selbst auflöst erledigt das die
stiftungsaufsicht und die liegt beim
justizministerium das heißt sie glauben
sie schon auf der richtigen seite sie
setzen sich mit ihrer rechtsauslegung
auch in diesem verfahren durch das will
ich hoffen also ich bin überzeugt weil
sonst hätte ich das so nicht beschrieben
auch
stiftungsvorstand erwin sellering hatte
kürzlich eine professorin für
stiftungsrecht präsentiert samt
gutachten mit einem völlig anderen
ergebnis sein wir können nicht auflösen
und ja wir würden uns
haftungsansprüchen aussetzen damit ist
für uns als stiftung eine auflösung vom
tisch eine kampfansage an die
ministerpräsidentin der streit um die
auflösung könnte vor gericht landen von
einem zerwürfnis mit ihrem amtsvorgänger
bild schwesig aber nichts wissen es gibt
keinen tiefen graben und natürlich gibt
es vielleicht verschiedene blickwinkel
auf dieses thema rechtlicher und
politischer natur aber das heißt nicht
dass es deshalb tiefe gräben gibt im
kern scheint es so zu sein dass herr
sellering der ja sowohl den ruß landtag
als auch nord stream zwei initiiert
hatte als ministerpräsident
möglicherweise sein lebenswerk
die freundschaft mit russland gefährdet
sieht und deshalb nicht einlenkt und das
ist natürlich eine herausforderung für
die landesregierung und insbesondere
auch will die ministerpräsidentin ein
untersuchungsausschuss zur klimastiftung
ist beschlossene sache mitte mai soll er
starten die opposition hat noch viele
fragen wo schwesig hat bisher sehr wenig
dazu beigetragen das ganze thema
aufzuklären sie hat ja von details
gesprochen die sich nicht kümmern möchte
sie muss sich jetzt an die spitze der
bewegung stellen es geht um den ruf des
gesamten bundeslandes
politisch ist die klimastiftung längst
zum sterben verurteilt tod ist sie noch
lange nicht
und weil der nachrichtenüberblick jetzt
hier mit diana um den krieg in der
ukraine ging es auch beim besuch des
bundespräsidenten in rumänien steinmeier
betonte im gemeinsamen gespräch mit
präsident johannes die große leistung
rumäniens bei der aufnahme von
geflüchteten außerdem versicherte er
erneut dass deutschland ein treuer
bündnispartner sei und forderte die
anderen eu länder zu mehr einsatz auf
rumänien hat eine gemeinsame grenze mit
der ukraine
deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten werden
keine malischen streitkräfte mehr
ausbilden die bundesregierung hat das
von der eu bereits beschlossene ende der
ausbildungsmission im westafrikanischen
mali bestätigt am rande der
regierungsklausur auf schloss meseberg
sagte
bundesverteidigungsministerium lamprecht
gut ausgebildete malische soldaten
könnten gemeinsam mit russischen kräften
furchtbare menschenrechtsverletzungen
begehen deswegen werde die mission
eingestellt
die stuttgarter staatsanwaltschaft hat
ermittlungen gegen baden-württembergs
innenminister strobl eingeleitet dabei
geht es um die weitergabe eines internen
anwalt schreibens an einen journalisten
und den verdacht der anstiftung zur
verbotenen veröffentlichung des
dokuments
hintergrund sind belästigungs vorwürfe
gegen einen hochrangigen polizisten
strobl hatte heute die weitergabe des
schreibens eingeräumt bestritt aber sich
damit strafbar gemacht zu haben
das bundeskabinett hat eine recht auf
eine mindestgeschwindigkeit beim
festnetz internet beschlossen laut der
verordnung muss diese bei downloads
mindestens zehn megabit pro sekunde
betragen bei uploads sind es 1,7 megabit
beide werte sind vergleichsweise niedrig
sollen laut digital minister wissing
aber die digitale teilhabe all jener
sicherstellen die bislang von der
versorgung abgeschnitten sind der
digital ausschuss des bundestags und der
bundesrat müssen der verordnung noch
zustimmen
hunderte kitas und ganztagsschulen in
deutschland blieben heute geschlossen
grund dafür war ein warnstreik aufruf
der gewerkschaft verdi dem tausende
erzieherinnen und erzieher folgten wie
hier in hamburg
die streiks waren teil einer warnstreik
woche in sozial und erziehungsberufen
mit der verdi vor der nächsten
verhandlungsrunde den druck auf die
kommunalen arbeitgeber erhöhen will ziel
sind bessere arbeitsbedingungen und
höhere gehälter
markus söder der bayerische
ministerpräsident war praktisch die
gesamte pandemie hindurch
selbsterklärtes mitglied im team
vorsicht beziehungsweise sogar dessen
ebenfalls selbst erklärter teamleader
wer ihnen aktuell auf den in bayern ja
traditionell flächendeckend
anzutreffenden volks bier und weinfesten
erlebt der kommt fast zwangsläufig zum
schluss dass söder mittlerweile
gewechselt ist hinüber ins team frohsinn
heute allerdings ist er in einer ganz
anderen sache unterwegs team
schadensbegrenzung denn dem
csu-parteichef söder ist sein
generalsekretär abhandengekommen
rücktritt unter noch immer nicht ganz
geklärten umständen aus münchen mehr von
stefan leifert
diesen auftritt hätte sich markus söder
gerne erspart dreieinhalb minuten länger
dauert er nicht mit gedämpfter stimme
und ohne rückfragen bedauert der
parteichef den rücktritt seines
generalsekretärs und den ausfall der zu
ihm führte für heute kann ich ihnen nur
das sagen wie ich empfinde zum einen
dass ich diese worte für inakzeptabel
halten
nicht darstellbar und auch kein
umgangsstil
aber es ist trotzdem alles schade und es
ist ein stück weit eine menschliche
tragödie die dahintersteht es war eine
geschichte der bunten die die tragödie
erst ins rollen brachte sie erzählt vom
unehelichen sohn meyers der verleugne
und dem er keinen unterhalt zahlen nach
veröffentlichung habe der csu mann den
reporter mit wüsten beschimpfungen und
düsteren drohungen überzogen 200.000
euro noch am gleichen tag gefordert
er hat die absurde these vertreten sie
haben mein leben zerstört
er wird mich vernichten er wird mich
ausfindig machen ich werde meines lebens
nicht mehr froh sein der verlag leitete
juristische schritte ein es gab keinen
anderen ausweg mehr als den rücktritt
eines generalsekretärs der die kontrolle
über sich verliert das wäre nicht die
wortwahl von uns allen gewesen und wir
waren auch über diese wortwahl wenn sie
denn so gefallen ist
erschüttert und würden sie auch nie
wiederholen und haben sie auch nicht
gutgeheißen das wollte ich ausdrücklich
an der stelle einfach sagen damit auch
das nicht im raum stehen bleibt das wäre
auch nicht verstehen der csu in meiner
sowieso nehmen mai als persönliche
tragödie ist so dass politisches debakel
stefan meyer sollte mission wiederwahl
managen die csu vor dem machtverlust
retten keine drei monate im amt bricht
so dass personelle neuaufstellung an
zentraler stelle wieder zusammen
eineinhalb jahre vor der landtagswahl
das ist eine mittlere bis große
katastrophe und zwar deshalb weiß söder
angetreten ist zu sorgen anderer
politikstil offenheit transparenz ja
mehr ehrlichkeit in die politik mehr
nachvollziehbarkeit richtige personen an
die richtigen stellen und es ist alles
gründlich schief gegangen
söder hatte sich grad in neuer rolle
versucht der landesvater der
traditionsbewusste der nabel der zuhörer
nachdem vorsicht nun team volksfest so
dass instagram account quillt über vor
leutseligkeit
doch die umfragen stagnieren und der
heutige rücktritt ist nicht das einzige
csu problem gegen ex-minister steuer
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft und ein
untersuchungsausschuss zur masken affäre
wird die csu in münchen über monate
begleiten
antworten geben vor allem auf die
landtagswahl die für uns die wichtigste
sind eineinhalb jahren zu jahresbeginn
hatte söder einen neuanfang versprochen
nun braucht er wieder einen und einen
neuen generalsekretär
und von der politik in der sendung jetzt
zum geld und da kam heute gleich eine
ganze reihe eilmeldungen hanna mit einer
meldung geht's los aus den usa die auch
signalwirkung für europa haben dürfte
die amerikanische notenbank fed hat den
leitzins angehoben das wurde auch so
erwartet allerdings ist der zinsschritt
dieses mal so hoch wie seit jahrzehnten
nicht mehr frank bethmann in frankfurt
warum genau es ist tatsächlich der
höchste zinsschritt seit jahrzehnten die
fed hebt den leitzins gleich um 0,5
prozentpunkte an und nicht wie sonst
üblich um 0,25 es ist ohne übertreibung
ein historischer abend eine zeitenwende
in der zinspolitik eben weil um die
frage zu beantworten in den usa die
konjunktur davon galoppiert und mit ihr
die inflation die preissteigerung lag in
den usa zuletzt bei 8,5 prozent und
damit so hoch wie seit 40 jahren nicht
mehr es ist also der versuch die
inflation wieder einzufangen auch in
europa steht einer zinserhöhung im raum
was bedeutet die entscheidung der fed
denn jetzt konkret für den euro-raum ja
noch hat die zinswende den verbrauchern
nicht viel gebracht ja die bauzinsen
sind bereits wieder gestiegen auch die
kosten für ratenkredite steigen doch die
zinsen auf guthaben also für guthaben
auf tagesgeld- und festgeldkonten
die bewegen sich bislang kaum begründet
wird das damit dass die sparzinsen im
direkter am leitzins hängen als andere
zinsen und den wollte die ezb ja bislang
nicht anheben nun ein umdenken in einem
zeitungsinterview lässt
direktoriumsmitglied isabel schnabel
erstmals durchblicken aus heutiger sicht
halte ich eine zinserhöhung im juli
ähnlich spannend aus verbraucher sich
daher wann steigen die sparzinsen
endlich wieder zumindest aber wann hört
das auf mit denen negativzinsen auf
einem höhere guthaben lanka nach
frankfurt gerne
heute ist in deutschland der so genannte
ehrt überlastung tag das bedeutet
bereits jetzt am
124 tag in diesem jahr hat die
bundesrepublik laut umweltexperten ihren
anteil der natürlichen ressourcen für
2022 aufgebraucht der wwf spricht
angesichts des frühen datums von einem
leben über dem limit gründe dafür seien
ein zu hoher energieverbrauch und co2
ausstoß durch verkehr und
massentierhaltung
die lottozahlen an diesem mittwoch sie
lauten 3 4 11 31 41 49
superzahl 2 alle angaben wie immer ohne
gewähr
und jetzt gleich im auslandsjournal eine
reportage über das schicksal
ukrainischer leihmütter ein immer schon
umstrittenes geschäft das jetzt im krieg
weitergeht mit schwangeren frauen auf
lebensgefährlichen reisen bleiben sie
also im zdf dabei
und gegen 0 uhr 24 gibt es dann unser
heute-journal update er sagen jetzt
christa und werden sie mögen bis morgen
angenehmer abend hinein
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt könnten wir ja
annehmen dass zwischen den hochs
westlich und östlich von uns und den
peas nördlich und südlich von uns das
wetter bei uns recht langweilig ist
genau das gegenteil ist der fall denn
dieses tief über dem mittelmeer das
bringt doch schwul feuchte luft heran
und der norden bekommt er kältere
temperaturen und so gibt es bei uns
tagsüber immer wieder kräftige schauer
und gewitter und die weiten sich jetzt
in der nacht auch weiter richtung
nordosten aus morgen ziehen sie da
langsam ostwärts und südostwärts ab dann
kann es vorübergehend auch am rhein mal
wieder für ein paar regenschauer
erreichen heute nacht bleibt ist zum
teil aber auch trocken hier zwischen der
ostseeküste und der mosel die
temperaturen sinken am oberrhein und in
der uckermark auf 10 grad in
norddeutschland auch am alpenrand geht's
zum teil auf 3 bis 1 grad runter da
droht also nochmal bodenfrost die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee und auch im
dauerregen im südwesten nur so bei 13
bis 16 grad sonst werden 15 bis 21 grad
erreicht und auch morgen gibt's wieder
regenschauer und gewitter von denen sie
hier im norden nichts abbekommen dafür
gibt es dann neue regenschauer am rhein
das ganze bei nordwest wird und in den
nächsten drei tagen wird der samstag der
durchwachsenen tag seien dann kommt
endlich auch mal regen in
norddeutschland der ist da ja hoch
willkommen in der nächsten woche sind ja
die eisheiligen wie sie aber hier am
temperatur und wettertrend für berlin
sehen können vor allem die wohl eher aus
bei temperaturen bis zu 25 grad guten
abend